one of the hardest working guys in
entertainment uh he also has quite
possibly the most impressive hit list of
all time all right here he'd go Nick
I Hit It First can you uh what's good
man I'll take the intro I'll take it
what's up beloved you're good yeah I
told you this because we had your call
on the show I was like I'm just glad you
ain't at Power 106 anymore because now
we can have you on the show I know man
but that's it I was talking to Big about
that it was always love it was always
love but you know like that's old
mentality like first of all everybody
owns all of their content now everybody
like so the people who like move like
dinosaurs I'm like this is our gang and
that's your game I agree with you you
gotta let that [__] go listen I totally
agree with you the problem is is that
there are people who are
but that's what I'm saying we can't be
maneuvering like well-paid servants you
know what I mean like yeah no there's
like my thing is like damn like I [__]
with like so many people at power 106.
but that was like first of all I never
like I didn't work for power 106. I was
partners with them so I heard did they
give you a restaurant or something like
that a little SLS deal or something
let's make some money yeah
and some SLS but that's what I'm saying
like we got to stop thinking like
especially I encourage anybody who wants
to get a new space of media or
entertainment uh specifically podcasting
already own your [__] because when you
do that then if if your boy got a
podcast I got a pocket then we can get
money together but this mentality of
like this is my station that's just
station that's when you don't own the
radio stations yeah like yeah that's
always like you gangbanging on blocks
you don't own yeah for sure it's like
you could wake up tomorrow and the
company can be like we're flipping yeah
and then you got to go get a job over at
the places and then the radio station
doesn't even
you're right so but that's why I was
always loved like it was never like but
I mean like you said the powers that be
some of them get still stuck in that old
school mentality of like the competition
is how we you know come on man we all
can get numbers we all can do our thing
what is something you learned from
because you've done radio a lot I don't
think people understand you are moving
to New York good
um you you still have the syndicated
show with always my my syndicated show
my syndicated countdown uh I've been
doing that for over a decade right
you've been doing that for a long time
but then like you know what did what did
you learn from the Power 106 experience
because it it obviously there was UPS
there was Downs yeah I think I think
again like I always say like you got to
move like a boss at the end of the day
and even more so like a leader I mean
like I I we know what that brand means
to our community to hip-hop and stuff so
the legendary radio station so that was
the whole purpose for me even being over
there wanting to be like look this I was
I had a daily talk show at the same time
uh I had you know Mass singer wilding
out so it was just the outlet for that I
felt like was a a real uh
probably like fixture in the community
that I could really harness and even
that time there was times where I was
you know they asked me if I wanted to
buy the station now the once once we
looked into it there's no point in like
you know it's probably overpriced yeah
you don't need to pay for dinosaurs you
know what I mean when you can go uh
create something of your own uh and
invest the same amount of money and you
own it 100 uh and you don't have to
worry about you know satellite Towers so
they offered you to buy it yeah oh wow
what did you could tell us how much it
was I mean it was 50 40. no no not that
much oh really it was less yeah yeah 20.
yeah so I'm wearing that around that
around that area so um but to say all of
that it's like you know even the things
like I've been able to you know I'm
probably one of the few people in
entertainment that I was able to have
deals that you know uh NBC and Universal
and fox and uh Viacom and all those
places at the same time it is kind of
crazy yeah I'm on every Network yeah so
give me your okay so when you're doing
mornings and you have the TV show and
you have mass singer and you have wild
and out yeah and you have don't forget
my new number one show celebrity Prank
Wars of Kevin Hart number one
and you have
the biggest family family known to man
me NBA young boy yeah he just had number
11. he had number 11. he
he because he started earlier than me I
had no kids I was 30. so what do you do
in terms of like just scheduling making
sure you don't go crazy making sure you
have time for the kids making sure you
have time for yourself yeah I can't even
imagine I'll tell everybody's like
energy management man if you see me I'm
cool calm and collected I know how to
manage my my energy probably better than
most I'm not I don't move off of emotion
or other people's energy uh because
people think it's time management but
time is a you know a man-made construct
that we all subscribe to like you can
get enough of that you can get but it's
it's having the right team and knowing
how to delegate your energy because you
I've been in situations where I've
overly stressed myself I've been in
situations where there was literally too
much on my plate and people were just
constantly pulling at me but when you
know how to manage your energy
um I think that that allows you to do
more than the average human being so
it's about the key would be delegation a
little bit of it I mean how to delegate
them because we got some people who
delegate in a way that like it is
stressful and it's toxic right but like
you just gotta allow people you know
people strengths you know people's
weaknesses you know the ability to say
all right I have this much to give then
I gotta go recharge right and also so
much of like everything you do you're
you're you have to be there yeah yeah
it's not like you're doing stuff you can
do from the crib or you can like do on a
laptop no you have to literally be in
front of a camera yeah but like somebody
asked me or tell me like man you don't
have no free time I was like all my time
is free time it's perspective it's how
you look at it everything I do I love it
so my vocation is my vacation so it's a
situation where like I would a lot of
stuff I'd get paid to do I would pay to
do you know what I'm saying and and I
think that's that's really the nature of
what I talk about managing your
bandwidth your spiritual bandwidth and
your energy because from that standpoint
we make time for the things we want
right and and you know as a father you
got to make that a number one priority
but then every nothing else is really
just a big ass Hobby